the Cowboys were calling but very very
trying to make an offer but we never
even got into taxes or numbers or
anything at that break we're not hanging
outside of things offer that's Emmanuel
Sanders and this one kind of came out of
the blue last Friday night there were
some talks about Emmanuel Sanders
drawing interest from the Dallas Cowboys
Chris and then just boom he's agreed to
terms with the Saints that's how the
smart teams do it not that the Cowboys
aren't smart but you keep it quiet you
don't let anyone especially if the
Saints if it gets out the Saints are on
that Emmanuel Sanders that's the kind of
things gonna wake up other teams cuz I
cave no doubt see something in this guy
other teams are gonna get in the mix
other teams are gonna throw more money
on the table
maybe the Cowboys accelerate their
pursuit but it was kind of stealth mode
for Sean Payton he got it done
and man this one makes a lot of sense
for the Saints when you've got Michael
Thomas who set a single-season record
for receptions and they really don't
have a solid obvious clear number two
all of a sudden Emmanuel Sanders becomes
that guy and he's gonna have a lot of
favorable matchups cuz everybody's
trying to stop Michael Thomas no doubt
about it I mean you're it's a perfect
fit for both guys for both I mean it's
perfect for the Saints it's perfect for
a manual Sanders a guy that's getting up
there in age he's not necessarily gonna
be the guy that could be on a go route
or a post route for 60 or 70 yards
you know consistently anymore but he's a
really good route runner he understands
defenses he's a veteran he's been around
other great quarterbacks it's a perfect
system fit and then to your point Mike
you're right I mean Michael Thomas is so
the go-to guy in that Saints offense and
if I remember correctly there's the it's
the biggest disparity between the number
one receiver on the team compared to the
number two receiver in all of football
well this will close that gap and
Emmanuel Sanders will be able to do some
of the things over the middle that
Michael Thomas does and
Sean Payton can move Michael Thomas
outside and command double coverage with
him or just create a mismatch with both
of these guys so you talked about
Emanuel Sanders Michael Thomas
Jared cook and then Alvin Kamara coming
out of the backfield damn that's pretty
good for Drew Brees and Sean Payton they
can be very creative with that crew
right there and even though the 49ers
gave up a third round pick and a fourth
round pick and ultimately got 10
regular-season games out of Emanuel
Sanders Kendrick born spoke to Matt Mayo
go of NBC Sports Bay Area earlier this
week and explained the impact that
Emanuel Sanders had on the young
receivers in San Francisco Chris from
born to Donte Pettis to debo Samuel and
that influence is going to linger we've
got more PFC live coming in red
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports